from someone who was unintentionally
funny to someone who is paid to be funny
Larry David he was on ESPN New York
recently talking about Lamar Jackson and
he claims that he was telling the Jets
because the big Jets fan he called Mike
mckagan in the former GM of the Jets
before the 2018 draft and recommended
that he draft Lamar Jackson I have a
witness he said I have a witness he gave
me the most condescending I told him
that he kind of laughed at me but but
who can blame him
no one thought Jackson was going to be
anything and then David went on to say
that they don't know who's gonna be good
they really don't when you think about
the fact that Bill Polian wanted to make
Lamar Jackson a receiver what does
anyone know they don't know anything and
he's right and Larry David was right and
Chris you were right you were all over
Lamar Jackson you and Larry David maybe
Larry David should buy a team and hire
you to be the GM you sign me up I'm all
for it I'll work for Larry David right
now let's go I could leave Larry David I
mean can leave you and go work for Larry
David I mean that's a win-win situation
trust me trust me Larry David around you
I would pay big money to just sit there
and watch him react to all of the stuff
that you say at any given minute well
yeah and then I'll react to his
quirkiness and say more crazy stuff so
it'll probably and probably work out and
be very funny that way but you know to
what Larry David saying first off you
know there's plenty of people in the NFL
that can evaluate quarterbacks you're
gonna miss at times and Lamar Jackson
you know it was a special special talent
that yes I did recognize but even like
even in the process I got so bamboozled
by coaches in the league
are you serious do you really think
Lamar Jackson like I even backed off a
little bit was like oh man maybe they
know something I don't know maybe I'm
not sure but either way the Ravens had a
vision of how to build it and make it
work for Lamar Jackson and I think
that's what we're seeing more than
anything is a team that went a different
route of going okay we don't need to
find the next Brady or Peyton Manning
and make it work that way we can make it
work a different way we got some pieces
in place and they had that vision and
they made it work and yes that's how I
always evaluated Lamar Jackson I never
thought like oh we got to make him into
you know a drop
passing quarterback like Sam darn 'old I
always thought part of the things should
be able to use his athletic talents and
all that and obviously Baltimore saw it
and they're reaping the benefits for it
now and Chris I've been doing this 20
years and I firmly believe that one of
the reasons why coaches were saying the
things to you that they were saying this
all traces back and and if any player
that chooses not to have an agent that's
his business but in the run-up to the
draft yes your buttons don't do anything
what they do is they get on the phone
with everyone they know and they sing
the praises of the guy they represent
and they trash the guys they don't so
Lamar Jackson in the run-up to the 2018
draft had no agent who was praising him
and every other Angeles traffic him all
the other quarterbacks right talking
crap about it right that debt that no
one was able to defend him on I think
what happens yeah the five guys taken in
round one he's at the very end of the
round yeah it's not a coincidence I'm
Mike I think that is a brilliant point
you're exactly right that he had nobody
fight no positive you know propaganda
down the stretch there the draft to
boost him up but I'm glad it works makes
a difference I'm glad I'm stuck my name
to him a little bit and for all those
who didn't believe in it you were wrong
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports